what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch some
epic rap battles we've been catching up
on some
and they just dropped the new one harry
potter versus luke skywalker why chitty
chat anymore
let's get into it
[Music]
whoa lego edition
[Music]
movies
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
like my father
harry i before
the two of us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
i think it's pretty clear that you and i
are pretty different
oh nice
[Music]
oh
twins since merry christmas oh my god
nice wizards of waverly places
oh dead serious oh that was good
oh that was clever that's like an mnm
kind of line
[Music]
oh damn [ __ ] that was good that one
and all about your primes something
about like your rhymes are flat
uh your rhymes are 2d2
i do think though in the end i mean if
you guys know me at all i'm
obviously a much bigger star wars fan
than i am a harry potter fan i really am
um
you're probably the opposite yes you've
read all the harry potter you're really
invested in in the wizarding world
for me though
i don't know man i'm i'm feeling like
harry took this one around like a second
or third verse because eventually
early on i was like i think harry's just
got this as it kept going
eventually luke was getting some good
sick ass bars in there some real good
ones
the burns were solid for uh in the last
half of luke skywalker's but
harry from beginning to end was just
like not
stop lethal the dispels all throughout
man i i really think harry took this one
i mean because even in like luke
skywalker's
there were times where i'm like you're
kind of making fun of star wars more and
less
harry potter don't get me wrong there's
there's a lot of those especially in the
latter half of his i felt like harry was
really good at the actual
insults about star wars and luke
skywalker yeah
exactly there's so many and his like
hinged on both references but also
just the ingenuity of like that's the
thing is i feel like both of them
were solid i mean luke definitely sh i
love talking about these people as
though they're actual
people that's sort of big rap battles
does to get you so good
it's so it's so lived in exactly it's
surprisingly so lived in like it's a
real rap valley
like [ __ ] i forgot this is just a comedy
sketch yeah
that's the thing so i was sitting here
going like okay man luke he showed up i
mean there's definitely some solid
rhymes and some some definite
burns in there but yeah from front to
back harry potter just had the mat
forgive the pun but the magic going
because it was like
references the word play the bars that
worked his word play
on their own there were bars that worked
his wordplay inside the realm of star
wars
like his just had everything for me
whereas the luke 1 had a lot of great
moments but
harry just just went full savage mode
for me on this
i really think in two in terms of a song
i love the build
yeah because it starts off where it
feels a little bit more
i feel like lin-manuel miranda could
have written this one
where it starts off a little bit slower
where you kind of feel like you're
listening to
kind of like a 90s hip hop rap
especially on luke skywalker's end but
as they keep going back and forth
it just gets getting faster and faster
than keeps getting
heavier and heavier and for another just
like going back and forth and throwing
down and with the sick ass animation i
like actually seeing in lego format
allows itself to do
way more anime and way more cool visual
graphics throughout
obviously it was animated by having that
be part of the support for the
background there was just way too much
to like
insult luke about yeah this was one that
really makes me want to go back
and just like some rap songs no matter
if they're comedy or not
make you just want to go and read every
bar and that's
this is one of those like because even
if it's meant for comedy like there's
such
great rhymes and flows in here like
what's the name of
that kind of wordplay like the dead
serious one where you're saying that
we're dead serious but the text is of
serious black
yeah it looks like a double entendre
yeah like when eminem says
words like invite them in like a one a
day yeah
you know and it's like that the double
meaning and then yeah
yeah that's just all that there's
probably like a whole lexicon of each
specific
facet of word right right that i'm not
naming well but
i don't care man that was sick i loved
it
yeah epic rap battles baby who won for
you
leave down why you chose them don't just
go because you know i'm a luke skywalker
fan of my hair
tell me who you think actually won guys
subscribe to erb
if you haven't done so already hit that
like button click that notification bell
yadda yadda
michael linden mikhail i'm so happy for
you because he lives out in sweden and
over there
it took him a long ass time to get
disney plus
they got a major delay for it this year
just a few months ago
finally got to have access to it he gets
to catch up on all these cool
disney films and i'm the man delorean on
top of that that's what he was
mainly itching to get excited for so
mikhail
as rough as 2020 has been and you've had
some scary experiences you've had to
deal with yourself just be grateful you
got the mouse in your house now okay
yeah you'll never be deprived of
princess films
marvel films the simpsons various other
family fair things stop complaining
probably not gonna watch
stop catching up on all these catch up
on disney classics actually every disney
classic
he is that's that's a real thing i don't
like the tv movies too
like that darn cat the remake okay you
just can't
has a hard time admitting he was wrong
about something all right
guys well thank you mikhail merry
[Music]
christmas